[موسيقى] لقد
أحببت الشاي دائمًا
منذ أن كنت طفلاً، وكان بارزًا
في ثقافتي وأعتقد أن الشاي
مفهوم عالمي بحد ذاته، فهو وسيلة
للانفصال عن المجتمع والهروب
من فقاعة السلام والهدوء.  بالنسبة لي، لقد
كان دائمًا ملاذي، كان دائمًا
راحتي ونعم كان حبي الأول هو
الشاي، مرحبًا، اسمي تانيا لوي وأنا
مؤسس بيت شاي تانيا
والصفاء في بيت شاي تانيا، وكان
مصدر إلهامي وراء افتتاح بيت شاي تانيا
هو  لأنني واجهت مشاكلي الخاصة
مع اضطرابات المناعة الذاتية الصحية المزمنة
أه الالتهاب المزمن وكان
الشيء الأكثر فائدة بالنسبة لي الذي ساعدني على التعامل
مع كل شيء والتنقل فيه هو الشاي وكان
ذلك مصدر إلهامي وراء
التركيز على أه وتثقيف
عملائنا بطريقة ممتعة و  بطريقة مرحة حول
جميع الفوائد الصحية الشاملة للشاي،
فبينما كنت أكتشف ما الذي نجح
وما الذي ساعد في علاج الالتهاب،
انتهى بي الأمر بإجراء دورة تدريبية وحصلت على
شهادة كمنتج،
المكون الرئيسي في الشاي هو الإلينين وهو
يساعد في علاج القلق.  يساعد في
إدارة الألم، ويمكن أن يساعد
جهازك الهضمي، وأسنانك، وشعرك، وأظافرك، وحالتك
المزاجية، وقد دخلت للتو في مجموعة
من العلاجات الشاملة التي لم أكن أعلم
بوجودها، فلدينا أكثر من 30 نكهة مختلفة من الشاي
في قائمتنا، أحد أنواع
الشاي المفضلة لدي هو  Golden Glow وهو
شاي العافية الأكثر مبيعًا لدينا، فهو يحتوي على
بتلات الزنجبيل والأناناس والشمندر والبابونج، ومن
بين أنواع الشاي الأكثر مبيعًا
لدينا هو الكرز المبهج الذي يعد في الواقع
محسنًا طبيعيًا للمزاج لأنه يحتوي على جذر
الأشواجندا وزهور الدر
وقطع الكرز فيه.  من بين أنواع الشاي المفضلة لدينا
هي نكهة عجينة البسكويت برقائق الشوكولاتة،
فهي تشبه الحلوى في
كوب [موسيقى] كبيت شاي. أنا أستمتع حقًا بجعل
العملاء يجربون أنواع الشاي لدينا
ويجربون نكهات مختلفة
يمكنهم في الواقع شم جميع أنواع الشاي
في مرطبانات الاستنشاق الصغيرة الخاصة بنا قبل أن
يختاروها، ولدينا نكهات ترابية،
لدينا ماتشا، لدينا المزيد من مزيج الفواكه،
لدينا مزيج من الحلوى، وكل
شيء بينهما عند إنشاء
بيت شاي تانيا، كنت أعلم أنني أريد
إنشاء مساحة تجمع بين الاثنين
إنستغرام ولكن الأهم من ذلك
أننا نحب أن نكون مكانًا آمنًا
حيث يمكن لجميع الفئات العمرية المختلفة والثقافات
والجنسيات أن يأتوا
ويستمتعوا بفنجان من الشاي والوجبات
الخفيفة